there was a routine property review
within GMP and in that property review
an officer discovered
um actually a fetus in the police
property system
and that fetus had just sat there for
two years
it opened up a can of worms and it
turned out that the fetus had been
seized from a young girl who became
known as Ruby in the drama three girls
that I worked on but Ruby had been
groomed sexually abused as a 12 year old
then a 13 year old she was made pregnant
when she was just 13 by one of the gang
of abusers
police says that fetus without her
knowledge without her consent without
her mum knowing and it had been put into
a police property system where it had
sat for two years nothing had been done
with it so when the property review was
done that fetus was found and they
decided that they had to do something
about this
um so I was brought in onto that job we
had
dozens of men when you were abusing
children
in and around Rochdale also in Oldham
I was asked to bring that young girl on
board as a victim by this time she was
14 I think
um I was asked to also bring on board
her sister who had also been
horrendously groomed and sexually abused
by dozens of men
but two years before she had been
arrested on suspicion of being a Madam
at the age of 15.
but I was told at that point that she
should never have been arrested which
she absolutely should not have
um that I was being asked to bring those
two children and their family and other
children potentially on board to tell us
what had happened and to prosecute this
gang of pedophiles
I spent eight months interviewing those
children and they named and identified
um multiple men
um Ruby gave her consent as did a mom
for us to use the DNA that proved who
had got her pregnant now she was a child
who had been 12
maybe even 11 but 12 to my knowledge
when the abuse began she had a statement
of special educational needs she was in
a special school she was being picked up
at the school Gates by her abusers
we had a fetus we had DNA that proved
who had got her pregnant he was a 40
year old man married with three children
of his own can you believe that even
that man was never charged with rape why
not because they took the easy option
and decided to charge him with sexual
activity with a child he was out of
prison in less than three years and he
didn't
she was not even made aware or consulted
about his release he was allowed to go
back to Rochdale where he still lives to
walk around where he bumped into her in
the local Asda walking around the end of
an aisle she went into a total meltdown
ran out of the shop and rang me in you
know floods of panic saying it was
called Billy that was his street name
his real name is Adil Khan and I I'm not
um his name is in the public Arena
because he was prosecuted and convicted
but he was out of prison in less time
than you get for you know parking on
double yellow lines sometimes
so I was [__] fuming
um my sorry I'm sorry I know I'm trying
to pick the big thing I just want to
there'll be people watching this going
what the hell is she talking about how
is how is it possible that in modern
Britain with all of that evidence that
you're talking about DNA fetus
statements Etc
somebody who's
just there to be prosecuted I understand
sometimes these cases are complicated
and you can't get the right information
and all of that but in this case it
doesn't seem to have been the case why
you say they took the easy option why
why did they take the easy option
because as
if she had been
the reason
no defense
it's statutory rape yeah yeah
because she was just 13 because the the
fetus and and the number of weeks
pregnant she was we knew exactly when
she'd got present uh pregnant because
she was just 13 that would have meant
that they would have had to prove that
she did not consent to her rape
in my book a 13 year old child with
special needs cannot consent in most
people's books yes but the CPS will say
well it's a lot easier to prove and they
don't have to prove anything then
because there's a fetus she was pregnant
we knew who he was so he had had sexual
activity with that child they didn't
want to go to a trial where they would
have to prove that she could not consent
so they took the easy option is that
money thing Maggie is it a lot of
resources and a money thing and it's
lazy yeah it's lazy and it's not right
no no it's not right and if that was my
daughter
I would want that man Prosecuting for
rape because she was not able to give
consent she was drunk every time she had
sex
we had a fetus as I keep saying so for
me that decision was made for resources
and because they couldn't be asked
basically but that doesn't make it right
it's wrong in relation to the other
young girl the other child who I had
been given promises that if I brought
her on board that I would be allowed to
hold her hand both their hands right
through to trial
eight months down the road again like
Augusta they may the powers that be so
Chief constables
um gold Commanders
people in CPS sat down and they made a
policy decision that they were going to
build a case around one child
and whilst I accept that because I know
that we can't always bring everybody
into one trial it becomes too complex
I do not accept that we cherry pick
which rapists we prosecute and which
children we support as victims if they
have given us evidence and they have
spent months identifying their abusers
and the top lawyer in the CPS has
identified them as a victim I'm sorry
you don't change your mind eight months
down the road and that's exactly what
GMP did again they changed their mind
and um it was it was if anybody wants to
watch the drama three girl it is a drama
it does not go nearly far enough the
police and the CPS get off very lightly
um again I'd say read my book but what
happened about eight or nine months down
the road after these kids had unburdened
their souls to me I spent every day with
them really
um they couldn't have done more to help
the police and eight months down the
road Friday afternoon
I just get you know my boss comes up to
me and says oh Maggie can have a word
yeah yeah of course you can this girl is
just identified 10 of her abusers in an
ID parade she fell apart but she'd done
it
because she didn't want the same thing
to happen to other children
um my boss said to me just want you to
know
um we've made a decision
we're no longer gonna use Amber
don't get upset we are going to use
Ruby
and I just felt
I just I just couldn't you know what I
would have I felt like murdering
somebody
and I just picked my bag up and I said
and this this scene in the drama is
actually pretty true I just said well
you know what I am not gonna use anybody
um it is not right and I was out of
there and
um
and I couldn't believe
that I was seeing and repeat again of
what I'd seen previously
foreign